hey what's up guys mkbhd here and ios 14
is here it was just revealed at wwdc
yesterday and i've had this beta on my
iphone this very early developer beta
for about a day now and after using it
for that time
there's actually a lot here both big and
small so this is the first look and
hands-on at the features and what to
expect for this os that will eventually
hit all your iphones in fall and
september around then when it comes out
brought to you by the six color shirt of
course also happy pride month so right
off the top i just want to say the memes
were pretty strong about apple taking a
a lot of old features from android in
this release i made the jokes we all
made the jokes but aside from all that i
think we should ask ourselves
why now
like why are we just getting widgets
instead of like eight years ago when
they could have added widgets to ios and
after actually using it i'm feeling like
the answer is
they wanted to get a couple extra things
right to put on top of it and it's not
like it's better than the android
version but there's some stuff that they
do their own way you'll see what i mean
so first up is the new home screen we've
all heard about it we've all seen the
widgets by now but let's just go over
everything first of all there's the new
app library which is a space all the way
at the end to the right of all the home
screens that's literally just a big list
of all your apps but automatically
organized this is basically the first
time ios has had like an app drawer
where everything's in one place
uh it took a decade but it's finally
here and inside of that there's just a
straight up alphabetical searchable list
if you're into that too now you can
still pull down to search from anywhere
on the home screens if you want to find
apps that way and actually adds more
results from the web and from siri but
hopefully you'll need to use this a lot
less and then of course
finally
widgets now it's still not quite android
level where you can put them like
anywhere you want and change them to
whatever size you want it's not the same
thing like you can't put a widget in the
middle of a home screen it has to be
either on the left side or the right
side which is kind of a bummer and you
can't put it alone on the right without
anything to the left of it so it's still
restricted in a very iphone way as you
can tell but at least you can long press
hit that plus button and break out into
all these new widgets and add them to
any home screen with some degree of
freedom you see there's different sizes
all the widgets here in ios 14 off the
bat are all first party apple apps and
and there's a nice variety with
different sizes and functionalities but
we are expecting third-party apps to be
coming as well and that to me is
exciting to finally be coming to the
iphone you know i'm looking forward to
having my tesla widget where i can
unlock the trunk of my car just from the
button or open the charge port or even
just have a widget of my google calendar
instead of an apple calendar so okay now
apple's added the fundamentals of
widgets are on the home screen so now on
top of that they've added a couple
interesting little dynamic nuances and
extra things you can do with that first
of all there's a widget you can add
called smart stack where once you add it
it's basically a carousel of several
common widgets and you can scroll
through them manually or have them
change automatically based on
predictions it's made for you and while
that's neat i didn't really think i
would use this until i found out you can
edit smart stacks and remove unwanted or
useless widgets from this carousel but i
think even cooler is the method of
adding
or creating your own smart stacks you
can do this anytime you want so if you
want to create a stack you can add two
widgets on top of each other that are
the same size so hold and drag that
second widget on top of the first widget
drop it on top and it becomes a
scrollable stack and then you can
continue to add more and then you can
edit to make it a smart stack or just
keep it this way that is pretty nice and
then another thing long overdue from ios
that you can now do because you have an
app drawer is hiding home screens
so let's say you have a couple apps that
you don't use that much as classic ios a
bunch of apps you don't use but you
don't want to delete them just in case
you want to use them once in a while
okay so instead of putting them all in
like a random folder that just sits at
the end of one of our home screens now
that there's an app drawer in ios you
can just hold down to edit
click the dots at the bottom
and then just uncheck to hide an entire
page boom now you never have to see
those apps taking up space on your home
screens again you can now actually make
a whole ios home screen setup with no
apps and just one page of widgets if you
wanted to so overall this home screen
stuff is definitely the biggest change
in ios then we have a bunch of changes
in this category that we'll call
compact ui so in previous versions of
ios there are plenty of things plenty of
actions that just unnecessarily take up
the entire screen
now they're all fixed so now when you
get a phone call or a facetime call for
example it won't just dominate the whole
screen anymore it'll just give you
another drop down notification from
which you can easily hide it and keep
doing what you're doing it'll keep
ringing or you can accept or reject
right away that's a good compact ui and
then once you're actually on a facetime
you can actually swipe up go home and do
other things and the facetime continues
doesn't pause your video it keeps the
camera up and working you can look
something up grab a phone number
whatever you're going to do it doesn't
have to pause and you can move around
that picture in picture as long as
you're doing all that and speaking of in
picture it's just generally more widely
supported throughout the entire os now
so whether you're watching a a movie in
apple tv in that app or just any video
in safari really and it's pretty
straightforward once a video is full
screen just swipe up to go home and that
video will shrink down and keep playing
in this little picture-in-picture window
and then you can play with the size of
that window move it around to any corner
and just keep doing whatever you're
doing behind that picture you can even
swipe it over to the side to get rid of
the visual for a minute but the audio
keeps playing in the background and then
you can bring it back whenever you want
keep going it really does feel more like
true multitasking and then lastly for
compact ui siri
which in all previous versions of ios
used to always be this full screen
takeover now in ios 14 is just a little
animation here at the bottom again
they've they've sort of adjusted it
but it's not perfect so you can call up
siri the same way long press the power
button and it's this smaller animation
at the bottom of the screen you ask it a
question it pops up an answer at the top
of the screen where it can but it
doesn't let you interact with anything
underneath directly without exiting siri
so while yes the animation is smaller
and it doesn't take up the whole screen
anymore it still doesn't quite feel as
much like the true multitasking where if
they let me scroll an article underneath
my siri answer
nevertheless you can still see what's
underneath there if you need to
reference it while you're talking to
siri then from there there are a lot of
little things useful things
but little things
i think to categorize them we'll put
them into two buckets straight from
android
and
genuinely new stuff that google should
copy so straight from android that stock
keyboard now finally has added emoji
search so instead of typing a word and
hoping the right suggested emoji pops up
now you can just search for any emoji
you want anytime which has revived the
age old question
is this emoji
prayer hands
or a high five
apple's keyboard does not service it
when you search for high five but
google's does apple is team prayer hands
google is team high five which team are
you on then there's a new stock
translate app which is nice to see it
only supports a smaller number of
languages looks like about a dozen right
now but i expect to see that list grow
over time and it works great for quickly
translating conversations between two
people and then finally default email
and browser apps will be able to be
changed in ios 14.
finally now it is it's just email and
browser apps but you know those are the
two that most people most often want to
set as a different default so i'm
excited to get chrome as my default
browser and i am very excited to have
something other than the useless to me
mail app as my default mail app then we
also saw app clips which is like little
snips of apps that you can quickly
temporarily use when you don't have the
whole app installed but need to use some
of its functionality a lot of good stuff
there but then we'll move on to the
super unique features that i haven't
seen some of this stuff wasn't even
talked about on stage but you know as
people dig through the betas we've found
some of it and it's good i want to start
with some accessibility settings so in
ios 14 if you go into settings
accessibility touch
and then back tap
you can now map a double tap or triple
tap of the back of the phone to a
shortcut so i've mapped double tapping
the back of my phone to open up siri so
literally all i do is double tap the
back
and after about half a second siri pops
up and then i think i did
triple tap to take a screenshot
and there it does it's a slight delay
but it does work and it's kind of neat
to have an extra thing mapped to the
back of the phone
i kind of wish opening the camera was
one of the available shortcuts
hey uh editor marquez here chime in with
a quick update you can actually set a
siri shortcut to run on that double tap
of the back of the phone and then you
can set that shortcut to point to any
number of things so at this point i
literally have the shortcut set to open
google assistant on a double tap which
is pretty hilarious
you could also have it open the camera
or whatever else you really wanted to
okay back to the video and then while
we're at it here's another really
interesting accessibility feature
settings accessibility
sound recognition this will let you turn
on notifications if the phone's mics
recognize a sound that might be
important so it's meant for people hard
of hearing but could still be useful to
anyone if it picks up a doorbell or a
fire alarm
or a faucet running that you forgot to
turn off that's pretty sweet there's
more memoji customizations they still
don't quite look exactly like me but at
least you can add face coverings like
masks another sign of the times along
with that hand washing detection from
the apple watch and then a privacy
feature
anytime literally any time an app starts
using the camera ios shows a little
green light to let you know that
something is accessing the camera and
anytime the microphone is accessed a
little orange light and then in the
improved faster camera app when taking a
night mode photo it gives you a
gyroscopic guide to help you keep the
phone still to take a better handheld
picture another one is if you're
facetiming and the ai detects that
someone in that group facetime call is
using sign language it will move them up
to the most prominent biggest spot so
everyone on the facetime can see the
sign language and there's also a ton of
other things on apple's site from the
pinned conversations and messaging to
cycling directions and ev navigation in
maps but clearly really most of the good
stuff
is in the details here's a list of all
the iphones getting ios 14 in the fall
again likely around september like they
do every year and so that's every iphone
since iphone 6s but overall
i think it's looking pretty good i mean
it's still it's not like a drastic ui
overhaul it's very clearly still an
iphone half the people who get this
update will probably never use most of
these features but there's a lot of good
ones baked in there for the nerds like
who want to dig in and actually use that
stuff let me know in the comments which
one's your favorite or if you're an
android person which one you'd like to
see google copy anyway until the next
one thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace